[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et pour commencer évidemment j'aimerais
ça va de soi saluer ma partenaire léa
salamé même si elle ne nous regarde pas
il doit être en train de regarder the
voice comme tout le monde je n'embrasse
de noix puisqu'elle a chopé le coup vide
mais je n'embrasse quand même entre nous
je me doutais bien qu'ils n'ouvraient
pas assez les fenêtres à france inter il
devrait attirer un peu plus souvent
parler discuter de ça
vous avez jusqu'à 40
la plaisanterie qu'il ne lâcherait
bois déjà depuis talent je m'ennuie
jamais mois a amené moi mon truc parce
que je vous ai préparé
faut que ça parte en tchat
ai je voulu dit tout
je ne sais pas on fêtera ses caisses et
lumineux je vous le dis tout matin à vau
l'eau sur ce plateau de mes pauvres
talents 6ème le vrac prix via quand même
sa majesté et on lui dit vous savez
madame sa grâce il porte le titre de
kraft puisqu'il éduque sa grâce va
changer d'avis c'est une passade c'est
un épisode la reine s'obstine rendez
vous est pris avec la jeune femme la
scène se déroule imaginez on est sous
les lambris tous les plafonds langues
le silence est très important on essaye
voulait qu'on essaye silence sur un
plateau de télévision en ce moment à 20h
avec les gens qui nous regardent vous
allez peut-être pour réussir moi je vais
avoir des grands moments de solitude à
10 15 secondes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on a juste fait 15 secondes c'est pas
mal non c'est pas mal ça fait du bien en
tout cas j'ai remarqué quand on reparle
ou même la voile est plus douce reja
plus apaisé ouais j'ai vu un chien pc
sur le plateau si j'y trouve c'est votre
choix c'est ça qui m'a un peu troublé je
reconnais dans le silence je me disais
mais c'est vrai c'était troublant parce
que j'ai vu passer
n'est pas terrible
mais les femmes comme ma mère
elle m'aide à rennes et france inter
elle est pacifiste elle est passionnée
elle est la solitaire est là
à
gauche benoît
elle est pas l est pas là et vous
intéresse cette campagne ou alors pour
de vrai comme quand vous comme vous
dites dans votre spectacle dont on va
parler dans un instant bah non non vous
trouve non vous ne parvenez pas à vous y
intéresser qu'est ce qui est vrai c'est
une pirouette c'est à dire je dis que ça
ne m'intéresse pas et en vérité
en vérité si je la trouve quand même
intéressant de pâtes pas parce qu'elle
dit quoi par le par le côté affligeant
finalement des débats des échanges et
beaucoup de gens sont inquiétés de mon
absence non lors du before
dernier cela ne portait pas d'initiative
je vous dis la vérité tu es sur ce que
j'ai je vous ai jamais menti chose je
veux demander aux chroniqueurs de ne pas
réagir ne pas me poser de question je
dirais toute la vérité rien que la
vérité
travaux
est ce que la reine des jeux a envie d'y
être
et parfois on atteint des sommets les
changes mélenchon eric zemmour dans
l'émission face à bah bah là a tout d'un
coup on atteint des sommets jeudi on est
même on n'est même plus à la cave on est
au sixième sous sol de la part de deux
personnes qui sont quand même
extrêmement cultivé et qui ont tous les
deux une forme de voile assez ici je
pense que deux personnes intelligentes
il a pas les mêmes valeurs
de respect du pacte de respecte tout ma
gueule avec des nôtres que demers de
coutume ami qui m'a mis des c
bien rien qui a l'air pur mariage
tharoor d'envoyer la moitié l'été ni
bach et haendel alors eh bien
tu avais mis une serviette de bain
cuisine et le maroc ne m'avait pas
minibar tarn était dégueulasse bétail
latine tu es malade était une sorcière
hélas si vous voulez c'est celle
invectives c'est le sait le mépris de
l'adversaire c'est il n'y a pas une idée
il n'ya pas y'a pas un début de
programme c'est une sorte de show comme
ça assez assez assez effrayant est
fascinant c'est de la politique
spectacle on regarde ces gens là parce
qu'on sait qu'ils vont comment dirais-je
des rails et que ce qu'est ce que ça va
partir dans les extrêmes c'est ses
instincts c'est un show qu'on garde
cher pays de mon enfant
bersée
soutien
[Musique]
des guerres des dents
va te faire cuire un oeuf
sur le plat sur le plat ou bien 2 si tu
te suit est mieux que ça
les vans encore une fois elles sont
pédagogiques c'est difficile délicat
d'expliquer ça parce que ça reviendrait
à expliquer ce que c'est le métier
d'humoriste nous quand y'a un truc qui
qui qui est chaud il faut qu'on y aille
c'est notre métier ce sont le reflet
d'une époque mais bon il essaie de
changer
on ne peut pas laisser passer on est en
concert on sert à la soupe voilà
exactement airs en sorte que les choses
des potions nous de rire des choses
graves avant d'avoir à en pleurer wucher
chantal vous êtes un peu le papa et la
maman de tous les choristes et accordez
vous d'accord rien et tout voilà il ya
la journée c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
je tiens à rassurer les téléspectateurs
ce sera sous titré
[Applaudissements]
ce qu'elle croit toutes ces petites
qui débat
je me cherche reyrieux
tu me parles
je courir
ouais
il était
alors ça peut paraître sombre et triste
l'enterrement vous pensez à votre
enterrement déjà c'est parce que toute
ma vie je me suis poil et j'ai pas envie
que le dernier jour ce soit un jour
forcément triste bon ce sera triste mais
j'ai envie que les gens fassent la fête
quand même donc j'ai choisi une chanson
c'est à ce qu'on espérait au fond de
cette boîte les sardines oui vous voulez
que votre enterrement gel des sardines
c'est un monde d'image la moindre chute
peut avoir des conséquences terribles
regardez regardez plutôt la chute de ce
concurrent ça va créer un effet boule de
neige les coureurs derrière son pied
j'ai ils tombent les uns à la suite les
à la suite des autres les uns sur les
autres belles et parfums d'enfance
dessus je peux vous dire ça ça va
laisser des traces d'eau peu tout ça et
là maintenant vous sentez comment je me
sens bien je sens bien une bonne douche
et un bon repas de la viande rouge sans
mayonnaise est un film de jean claude
van damme et c'est reparti